former president trump
leaves office with one last parting shot
of corruption because
of course he would his last acts in
office included a raft of pardons
that are bad they are historically bad
even without the prior pardons and
grants of clemency that involved
pardoning
paul manafort and a bunch of his cronies
this would have been amongst the most
corrupt and despicable group of pardons
in history
but even as bad as they are it's hard
not to take a step back and recognize
that
it could have been so so much worse
but finally it seems that there might
actually be a silver lining here because
the bar
was so low with this presidency that we
can finally step over it for once so
let's take stock and let's see the good
and the bad here
let's start with the bad news first
because these pardons
are bad they are historically bad we
start with
a pardon for friend of the president
steve bannon
bannon was facing a trial for fraud in
connection to the build the wall
campaign
and all signs point to bannon stealing
millions of dollars from
actual trump supporters and it's also
notable that
other build the wall defendants who have
also been accused and indicted of fraud
were not pardoned it was
just the president's friend as former
representative justin amash said it went
from mexico will pay for it to you will
pay for it too
you will pay steve bannon and i will
pardon him for defrauding you
there's no good reason for this pardon
there's no reason at all for this pardon
except that it's good to be a friend of
donald trump and swear omerta to him and
then of course takes us to another good
friend of donald trump
elliott broidy who pleaded guilty last
year to conspiring to violate foreign
lobbying laws
to influence the trump administration on
behalf of chinese and malaysian
interests
and he of course was implicated in what
is now known as a pay for pardon scheme
is there anything corrupt with this
particular pardon for a republican
fundraiser who happens to be friend with
the former president
all signs point to yes on that one and
then there were more
pardons for corrupt republicans like
rick renzi and duke cunningham
renzi is a republican and former member
of the house who was sentenced to three
years in prison
in connection with a bribery scheme
related to real estate
cunningham also pleaded guilty to taking
2.4 million dollars in bribes
from military contractors these are not
good people and there's just this
pattern of pardoning outright
criminal corruption just we've never
seen anything like it with presidential
pardons before
yes a lot of former presidents seem to
have a habit of pardoning light
corruption for those who happen to be
well connected
but here the worse the corruption the
more likely to get a pardon and the
corrupt are a preponderance
of the pardons it exists on both sides
of the aisle while there's certainly a
preponderance of corrupt
republicans who have received pardons
that pattern continued with pardoning
former detroit mayor kwame kilpatrick
who was convicted in 2013 for using his
office to enrich himself
through kickbacks shakedowns and bid
rigging schemes
president trump was clearly favoring his
friends and business partners but
at the same time he was just setting a
precedent for
absolving pure corruption pure political
and business-related corruption
as political commentator josh barrow put
it they only make sense as a general
statement that corruption
is good and that pattern of pardoning
just
outright corruption specifically with an
emphasis on real estate corruption
continues with
the list of people who received pardons
for example shalom weiss who was
sentenced to more than 800 years in
prison for racketeering fraud and money
laundering related to
insurance fraud and then ilyahu
weinstein who was sentenced to more than
20 years in prison for a real estate
ponzi scheme that
cost 200 million dollars in damages and
then oddly
anthony lewandowski who pleaded guilty
to stealing
ip related to driverless cars when he
left google to go to
uber and the list of overtly corrupt
individuals who received a pardon
is extremely long but lest you think
that trump was
only pardoning corruption he also
engaged in pure cronyism like pardoning
new york observers ken kersen
who was charged with cyber stalking last
fall and who happens to be a very very
good friend of jared kushner and then as
potentially the very last act in office
president trump had
one last pardon to dish out after the
wrath that he released
at 1 30 in the morning he also pardoned
albert pirro who was a real estate
developer and
notably was the ex-husband of judge
jeanine pirro from fox news
pirro had been convicted of conspiracy
and tax evasion in 2000 and
had actually represented trump himself
in some real estate deals
to say that these people are undeserving
of pardons is
a vast vast understatement and of course
potentially as a cherry on top at one
o'clock in the morning
president trump revoked his 2017 drain
the swamp memo
which prevented members of the white
house from lobbying the government for
five years so that
the members of his administration can
now lobby the government
it is time to drain the swamp in
washington d.c
in retrospect looking at all of these
actions which were entirely foreseeable
it's not hard to see why people who
thought that president trump was the
anti-corruption
president and would actually drain the
swamp also happen to believe in stupid
conspiracy theories and absurd
prognostications
that never came true but if you did
believe any of those preposterously dumb
things
please contact me i have some really
interesting investment opportunities
you might even call them unbelievable
but let's
also take stock that this actually could
have been
much much worse president trump
could have pardoned himself and caused
an actual
constitutional crisis now of course the
masochistic sportsman in me kind of
wanted to see it
just so that that theory that the
president could pardon himself
would be smackdown in front of the
supreme court as part of a trump
corruption and criminal investigation
it's also entirely possible that trump
could have pardoned members of his
family including ivanka jared kushner
don jr eric
kimberly guilfoyle and it appears that
he really really wanted to do that but
that white house counsel pat cipolloni
said it would open trump himself up to
personal liability or criminal liability
and so the reason for him not
undertaking these actions which he
apparently wanted to do
is that donald trump is selfish to the
core and is willing to throw his own
children
under the bus it's possible that he
could have pardoned his own personal
attorney rudy giuliani who's under
investigation for many fraud related
things
it's also entirely possible that
president trump could have pardoned his
own personal business associates like
trump organization cfo alan weiselberg
who also has been implicated in all
kinds of trump-related fraud
he could have pardoned the capital
rioters he could have pardoned some of
the congress people
who helped foment some of the capital
rights including
congressman biggs and gosar who
apparently sought pardons for their role
in creating the capital riots and one
has to ask
if you're looking for a preemptive
pardon are you worried about criminal
liability related there too
i'm going to cover this in a video
shortly we're lucky that there were only
a handful of celebrity pardons for some
reason including
lil wayne kodak black and harry oh of
death row records
and joe exotic of tiger king fame is not
amongst the partners
and the ultimate good news is that none
of these pardons affect the impeachment
trial in the senate that remains
in the short-term horizon and of course
a new department of justice can create
new criminal investigations and unearth
all of the untoward
doings of the late trump presidency
of course it's going to take a long long
time to undo the damage
of the trump presidency but like a loud
orange fart
the noxious trump presidency is already
departing the room
and of course it's important to
recognize that none of this was normal
the trump presidency ended like it began
as former president george bush said
with some weird and i look forward to
covering the biden administration i will
cover
any dubious legal strategies that they
undertake my lawsuit against the white
house will continue because it's about
transparency not about partisanship
but make no mistake the last four years
were not
normal and as a reminder donald trump is
now a private citizen to the extent that
he ever had immunity as president
he no longer has immunity for anything
these pardons are largely unjust
but they likely won't have systemic
reverberations or
at least those reverberations should be
dampened
many who received these pardons might
even face
civil and state-based criminality down
the line these pardons are bad
but they're likely not earth-shattering
by all appearances
the damage of the trump administration
was extensive
but it's contained and now it's time to
clean up the mess